foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in today's video we're
going to be discussing 10 things you
probably missed while you were watching
the Philosopher's Stone film I'm also
going to be doing a separate video
highlighting 10 things you probably
missed in the book but today let's focus
on the films hunting for Easter eggs and
interesting tidbits within the Harry
Potter films is one of my favorite
pastimes there's just something so
special about looking through the halls
of Hogwarts and discovering something
you've never realized before so today I
thought we'd spend some time doing just
that this time we'll take a look at the
very first Harry Potter film the
Philosopher's Stone and see what
interesting Feats and facts we can find
10. Ann Bolin the witch the corridors of
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry are filled with the portraits
of famous witches and wizards from
around the Wizarding World now when you
think of the various famous source who
adorned the walls of the school who
comes to mind you might first imagine
the headmaster's office where all of
Hogwarts previous head administrators
have their portraits hung while in
charge of the school Albus Dumbledore
would famously receive some good and
some bad advice from the paintings in
his room Sirius Black's ancestor a
former Headmaster around the turn of the
20th century was one of the most
talkative of the bunch
but while watching the Philosopher's
Stone if you squint your eyes you can
make out the image of Anne bollin in a
portrait of course you'll remember
bollin as one of Henry VIII's wives but
she was also slandered as a witch for
years by hanging her portrait in
Hogwarts the filmmakers give a small
wink and Nod to the tragic history that
befell many political enemies throughout
the ages of England and the severity
that the accusation of Witchcraft
carried 9. Warner Bros logo the Harry
Potter films are richly filled with law
and symbolism from the complex
architecture of Diagon Alley's craft
stores to the leather band volumes that
filled the goblin Bankers shelves at
gring Gods there's enough history within
this world to fill an entire
encyclopedia but before the films even
begin you might notice that even the
Warner Bros logo has its own story to
share in order to reflect the
progressively darker Tales of each Harry
Potter book The Warner Bros love go
itself becomes dimmer and more ominous
with each film this means that the
Warner Brothers logo animation that
precedes the Philosopher's Stone is one
of the lightest ones if you compare it
to the logo from Deathly Hallows you can
really see just how much they contrast
8. mg McGonagall on the Quidditch trophy
Minerva McGonagall was one of the most
skilled transfigurationists in all of
England but her relatives might have
been famous for something far different
when you think of McGonagall you
probably imagine a venerated old teacher
with enough magical knowledge to battle
even the toughest Death Eater but when
you take a look at the walls of Hogwarts
you'll notice that the McGonagall name
is etched into a quidditch plank
alongside Harry's Father James Potter
this name specifically was mg McGonagall
and while there were certainly more
branches of this family in Britain than
Minervas it's hard to imagine that there
were actually that many who were also
magically inclined considering just how
inter-related all the Wizards and
witches were in England I mean even
Voldemort was related to the blacks and
distantly The Potters
this famous quidditch McGonagall might
have very well been Minerva's niece or
nephew 7. Aunt Petunia reusing Dudley's
old uniform in the background if it
weren't for Hagrid's sudden arrival in
Harry Potter's life then the young
Wizard's education would have turned out
much differently originally Potter's
adoptive parents never intended to send
him to a Wizarding School in fact they
never really thought much of educating
the boy in the first place unlike their
biological child Dudley who they
enrolled at the best Academy in the city
the dursleys intended to send Harry to a
particularly horrible Institute
Stonewall high and unlike their precious
Dudley's vibrant school uniform
stonewall's dress code required dull
prison-like garbs and if you look in the
background of some of the earliest
scenes of the Philosopher's Stone you
can clearly see art petunia dying
Dudley's old clothes to a drab gray the
perfect color for Stonewall 6. Harry
scar burning throughout the first Harry
Potter film The Young wizard trying to
get to the bottom of one of his greatest
Mysteries why does his scar burn at
times Harry wrongly assumed it was due
to any number of factors even believing
Professor Severus Snape must have been a
cause but if you look carefully at some
of the scenes in the film Harry's scar
Hurts the Most when Professor Quirrell
has his back turned towards him and that
meant Voldemort was looking directly at
him now fans of the book and repeat
watches might not have found this scene
particularly significant but for new
fans and young children who didn't grow
up with Potter law this tiny tidbit adds
a rich layer to repeat watchings 5.
symbolism by this point you'll notice
that most of the Easter eggs and Ted
beds deal with gryffindor's and the good
guys but there were some scenes that
played out with the lore of Southern as
well in the beginning of the
Philosopher's Stone Harry Potter to
accompany the deserts on a trip to the
local Zoo to celebrate dudleyan's 11th
birthday then Harry found himself
surprised to discover he could converse
with snakes but if you pay closer
attention to the scene you'll also
notice that a group of school children
quickly walk past the reptile house
adorned in bright green uniforms The
Outfits bear a striking similarity to
the house colors of Hogwarts Slytherin
house and is a nice bit of foreshadowing
about the origins of Potter's parcel
tongue ability 4. Voldemort in the
credits after the film finishes in the
credits roll you might be curious to
search for the original actor who first
portrayed Lord Voldemort obviously in
later films the actor was replaced for a
higher profile star Rafe finds but in
the Philosopher's Stone the well-known
television actor Richard Bremer took on
the role if you look through the credits
though you wouldn't find a listing for
Lord Voldemort instead stand the
filmmakers listed Bremer as he who must
not be named this subtle distinction
continued the ominous terror-inducing
mystery that surrounded Voldemort's name
three Uncle Vernon's Strange Day for
fans of the film The omission of Uncle
Vernon's bizarre wizard-filled days that
preceded Hagrid's arrival was one of the
biggest disappointments in the books
before Harry Potter was ever introduced
to the Wizarding World Uncle Vernon
started to notice a few strange men in
funny-looking hats and other bizarre
Oddities that foreshadowed the Havoc
that was to come 2. voice changes by the
timely Philosopher's Stone was filmed
the main cast was already approaching
the period in their lives when their
body would undergo all of its major
changes and for later films this meant
that Harry and his friends wouldn't
always have their childlike Elementary
School voices by the time the Chamber of
Secrets began production nearly the
entire maincast voices had changed for
this reason the Philosopher's Stone has
the rare distinction as being the only
film that captured the cast's youthful
voices in all later movies their voices
matured in the same way the themes would
1. the ruins of Coral's game when
searching for the Philosopher's Stone
Harry Potter eventually arrived at a
final room where quarrel and a parasitic
version of Voldemort desperately trying
to get their hands on the alchemical
tool but if you paid attention to the
challenges in the preceding Chambers you
might have seen evidence of Coral's
progress especially in the Wizarding
chess chamber where there were shattered
ruins of the Towering chess pieces from
the brief period before when Quirrell
played his own game there this was only
a small Touch by the production team but
it adds a layer of believability to the
film as you well know we nitpicking fans
are all too eager to point out the
inconsistencies in the books and films
and it wouldn't take long for us to
wonder where all of Coral's pieces were
after all he couldn't possibly have been
skilled enough to win the game with
something as Flawless as a Fool's mate
and there you have it 10 things you
might have missed from Harry Potter and
the Philosopher's Stone now I chose the
ones that piqued my interest the most
but there is certainly no shortage of
interesting factoids from the film what
are some of your favorites I hope you
share them in the comments below
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry and the rich world of the
magical Community surrounding it is
filled with more than enough lore to
explore and that's it for this video if
you enjoy the content please be sure to
like the video and subscribe to the
channel stay tuned for more videos like
this from the other films as well as a
series focusing on things you missed in
the books until next time remember there
is plenty to be learned even from a bad
teacher what not to do how not to be
[Music]